The loser's pretty obvious.
They get pushed around, they curl up, hide in a corner.
A lot of the time, when there's initial contact,
if one of them is too much on the defensive side,
the second one will sort of poke at it, grab at its tentacle and see,
"Hey, do you want to fight me, do you want to turn around?
Do you want to start a wrestling match?"
So it'll just poke and run away. Come back, poke and run away.
(Bell ringing)
Rule 2: Avoid eye contact.
When the octopuses come towards each other to begin the fight,
they don't actually face each other.
They approach sideways.
The defensive octopus tries to face away from the attacker
until it's the critical moment it knows there's no way to avoid a fight.
GG: Really, the one who's waiting to the last moment
is the defensive octopus.
(Bell ringing)
Rule 3: Flash your colors.
The aggressor in a fight will quickly and sharply flash bright black on his arms
when he's about to initiate a fight.
(Bell ringing)
GG: Ooh, and already --
IC: We're seeing some action.
Looks like they've spotted each other.
GG: Right. So now he's going to come -- He's approaching, but not directly at him.
IC: Yeah, they're like almost completely antiparallel.
GG: And then right there --
IC: Yeah. They contact, and then their arms clash together.
(String music)
GG: So we've taken the first steps in understanding fighting in the octopus.
And you might be asking yourself: Why does this even matter?
Well, these types of curiosity-based research questions can often lead
to some unexpected insights and discoveries.
We've learned a lot about ourselves from studying marine animals.
Squid have taught us about how our neurons communicate,
and the horseshoe crab has taught us about how our eyes work.
So it's not too far of a stretch to say that some of these behaviors
that we're seeing in the California two-spot octopus are similar to ours.